alright Starbucks just announced a new
policy that lets people hang out and use
the bathroom without ever having to buy
anything
this was their PR response to that big
screw-up when two black men were
arrested for hanging around in one cafe
in Philly
now Starbucks rely realizing they just
sent an open invite to the nation's
homeless now says sleeping drug or
alcohol use will not be tolerated so how
will this work
well like panicky responses the
consequences won't be borne by the execs
the CEO won't be on the frontlines he'll
be too busy monitoring his company's
Twitter feed instead baristas
people making far less money than the
consultants will be forced to ask other
patrons if someone's behavior bothers
them before taking action so this whole
thing is gonna end up looking like a
rerun from cops oh my gosh and it puts
pressure on employees and later the
police who will be blamed by both the
unruly patrons and social justice
warriors now present at these overpriced
coffee-- temples as you know 8,000 Plus
locations will shut next Tuesday for
unconscious bias training I call it a
will Cochino unconscious bias training
you see the trick there since it's
unconscious how can you deny your bias
it's automatic and invisible so you
can't know you're a bigot only in
today's PC America could a coffee shop
decide that it's the moral conscience of
the nation so Starbucks keep the new $7
virtue signal veinte we drink coffee to
be awake not woke that was a good one
thank you your next book vol 2 I thank
you I have monologues I'd like to share
with America bring up the full screen
okay why this puts the responsibility on
the baristas who just want to sell
coffee and they're gonna end up becoming
mental health professionals in New York
there are people that are unstable that
come into these places and and it's a it
can be pretty ugly you can't put that
kind of pressure on people you know
you're cranky today so I'm gonna forgive
a lot he's got a source that strap we
love you but you're cranky today so
anyway I just want to say this is a rare
moment when I agree with because I'm a
regular Starbuck
customer and but the thing is Greg I go
in and I get upset if I can't use the
bathroom because it's occupied right
ones in there for hours but I also get
upset when I can't find a place to sit
or even stand yes because guess what
it's not homeless people but it's
oftentimes young people but they're who
they got their computers they got this
and now I will lay there for hours right
so I get it but then I feel like you
know what I am a privileged little snot
because my wife said to me and other
people have said to me that Starbucks
intentionally created a culture where
they're a coffee shop where they're the
so called third place where you can meet
your friends where you can have debates
where you can work and then all of a
sudden you say well but that guy looks
kind of threatening where that guy looks
like he's poor and he can't be in here
well that's a contradiction and then all
of a sudden you do get involved in are
those two guys we're asking to use the
bathroom just bums or they just two
words Duncan don't act like this with
the nonsense it's a no one's trying to
discriminate
are you buying something in there do you
have something you'd like to purchase to
stimulate the economy or do you just
want to come in and clog the toilet and
take all the tables by the way it's
Brian you can't if you imagine doing
this at any restaurant where you walking
to I'm just gonna hang out you can't the
you go to a Greek diner in Midtown
they'll throw you out language but it's
a restaurant it's but I will say this I
this one this is your best block in a
long time we down three different Road
I'm totally I can't beat that but I
would say this I would say I'd know
fundamentally I cannot use somebody's
bathroom or get changed - pee - pee -
pay a toll unless I buy something from
that store I just know that that's it
courteous it's like courteous right if
you're going to use the 7-eleven
bathroom and you know biased Snickers
the Starbucks and the dunk it don'ts
have one thing in common their bathrooms
are way too big you can land a
helicopter in them we just need a small
bathroom
I like the big bathrooms gonna be a
lawsuit just so you know
someone's gonna be injured or stabbed or
stocks happened and then that's it for
this oh you won't go or you're gonna
have your own call you know Brian
there's somebody over here that hasn't
st. no Fox & Friends all right but
you're not turning David this is
actually a failure of society and a way
to figure out what to do with the
homeless this is like our band-aid well
a couple things one so this falls into
my PR law that every overreaction will
cause an equal or greater overreaction
to be nurple and then this was going to
have all right in your book maybe put
this back in there I am for better and
more public restroom okay that doesn't
have to be at somebody's private
business but if this private business
decides that this is what it wants to do
okay knock yourselves out but I would
rather go to Duncan yeah there you go I
think we solved one of the world's
greatest problems
ladies that way those send us some stuff
before the show's over yeah yeah make a
suggestion for some Febreze in the
bathrooms that just covers it up